[Musique]
emmanuel macron ne s'exprimera pas dans
les prochains jours le président se
laisse jusqu'à la fin de la semaine pour
analyser les effets du couvre-feu à 18
heures et la raison de prendre son temps
au nez dans le en même temps sanitaires
je crois que ces atermoiements
déstabilise aujourd'hui beaucoup notre
pays
les français n'y comprennent plus rien
moi j'appelle à la clarté
on essaiera de prendre à l'édition qui
seront les plus appropriés possible ça
peut être un recond finement et lampe
est un recrutement adapté en fonction
elle a encore le temps oui j'en ai le
temps là oui quand ça et scientifique
d'ailleurs à l'adie at il reçu un coup
de fil du ministre de la santé ou
peut-être même au dessus
en tout cas il nuance sérieusement ses
propos ce matin en une de libération
nous ne sommes pas encore dans l'extrême
urgence on n'est pas à une semaine près
d'idées le flanc est-ce qu'il a raison
il ya sûrement des informations dont je
ne dispose pas donc que vous n'avez pas
en tout cas je l'espère ce qui est
certain c'est que la situation est
aujourd'hui assez dégradés puisque la
moitié des lits de réanimation va plus
de la moitié des lits de réanimation en
france sont pris par des malades
qu'ovide à ma connaissance et sur la
base des données dont nous disposons à
ce stade il n'y a pas de raison de faire
de décider un confinement et on
continuera je crois que les français
n'attendent ni excès de zèle ni laxisme
et c'est très exactement dans cette
direction que nous allons of la presse
est pas là nous étions avec le gt1 qu'on
fait en téléphone avec le préfet qui
malheureusement nous annonce un recond
finement dès mercredi
assez dur annoncé à part annoncé
mercredi soir à partir de jeudi
sauf les écoles et tous ferme comme en
mars
voilà et c'était très précis comme un
don vous avez entendu ce problème dans
la foulée le préfet a démenti cette
information
il affirme n'avoir jamais dit ça au
maire de cabourg bref on y comprend
vraiment plus rien alors le maire de
cabourg il fait ma joie ce matin
tristan duval puisqu'il dit on a mal
compris ce que j'ai voulu dire
alors là j'aurais dû préciser que cette
décision sur courte réflexion et ne pas
mêler la préfecture le maintien dont
sur la base des informations dont je
dispose le délai d'injection entre deux
injections
pfizer à 21 ou 28 jours c'est à dire
trois à quatre semaines et je demande
donc à l'ensemble des acteurs qui
organise et réalise cette campagne de
vaccination sur le territoire national
de s'en tenir à une recommandation que
je viens de porter en floride presque la
totalité des restrictions sont levés
alors les américains de tout le pays
viennent ici en quête de liberté
j'ai plein d'énergie de la côte ouest
ils sont venus en floride pour revivre
l'expérience des restos et autre chose
quelle idée pour certain que si monsieur
attali avait prévu cela a quand vous
avez des infos exactement et c'est qu'en
fait il fait partie des personnes qui
auraient été créés ou qu'il en est
l'auteur ou qu'il en est l'auteur c'est
surtout voilà qu'il en est l'auteur en
tout cas ils complotent avec séjourne à
monsieur attali défend aussi des
solutions globales sur certains
problèmes l'écologie notamment et donc
ça ce serait la preuve qu'en fait c'est
pour asseoir un ordre mondial qui serait
globalisé avec un gouvernement unique
pour emmanuel macron les présidents du
climat je pense que le président mac
macro est le miroir de notre société
il nous ressemble quand il ya la marche
pour le climat à paris en mai 50000
quand il yal'arrivée la coupe du monde
dont les deux millions qu'on sera 2 à 3
millions à manifester dans la rue on
aura le président du climat je pense je
ne prône pas un gouvernement mondial ça
n'a aucun sens il y aura peut-être un
deux siècles mais je pognon draps
parlais tout à l'heure des règles
internationales
si on avait eu des règles sur les
marchés de gros qui s'appliquerait à
luan comme ça s'applique à régis on
aurait sans doute pas eu la pandémie si
on a maintenant des règles sur
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux la
défense du vrai vous vous l'aurez pas
les défectueuse dont il est vrai qu'on a
besoin du règlement par ce qui s'est
passé à oklahoma city pour ce concert
des flaming lips est un célèbre groupe
de rock alternatif
les membres du groupe et les spectateurs
sont confinés dans des bulles individuel
gonflable en plastique qui vise à
empêcher évidemment la propagation